a federal investigation is underway to
determine if a brand of bottled water
sold in several states
made people sick and might have put them
at risk of needing
liver transplants real water is what
it's called it issued a nationwide
voluntary recall on its alkaline water
after discussions with the fda
but many questions remain about the link
between the water
and some kids getting sick our consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has been digging into all this for us
anna good morning to you what'd you find
good morning tony you know many people
buy bottled water because they believe
it's healthier
but federal investigators are now
looking into questions
about one particular bottled water sold
in stores
and by home delivery and we went to las
vegas to investigate for ourselves
real water is the world's premier
enhanced bottled water
that's real water founder brent jones in
a youtube video
explaining the benefits of his company's
bottled alkaline water
including assisting with better cellular
hydration
and creating an antioxidant effect in
the body they sold the water nationwide
offering home delivery of five-gallon
water bottles in las vegas
to people like ryan and erica carrier
it's advertised quite a bit
in las vegas they have the trucks around
town that say real water on it
right why this particular water we
thought we were giving the best water
that our family could drink having this
alkaline ph water and i like the taste
of it
i did their two-year-old son finn and
five-year-old daughter hera drank it too
but last year hara started getting sick
constant complaining mommy my tummy
hurts
i don't feel good then in november she
got
really violently ill she had stopped
eating at that point because all she was
doing was throwing
up tara soon became incoherent they
rushed her to a local hospital you don't
know what's going on with your daughter
you're putting her in the back of the
car
limp in the car seat it was excruciating
excruciating there doctors told erica
the five-year-old's liver was
failing and what's more they couldn't
treat her there
she would have to be life flighted to
salt lake city for a possible
liver transplant it's absolutely like
going into shock
you know thinking that your
your five-year-old might need a
transplant
how many things make you follow your
knees in life right you
fully off we fell to our knees right and
we all prayed
their prayers were answered hera avoided
a transplant
but it wasn't just their child over just
11 days health authorities said five
children between the ages of
seven months and five years became ill
all at risk of needing liver transplants
health officials say the only common
link between all the identified cases
was the consumption of real water brand
alkaline water
six weeks ago the company announced a
nationwide voluntary recall
we wanted to ask about what happened to
those children so we went to the
company's office
but it was empty just a few trucks
sitting outside
real water later declined our request
for an interview
but online founder brent jones said this
we'd like to express our deepest
sympathy and concern over the events
that led to the inquiry
in a video posted to his website in
march jones apologized to his customers
we have issued a voluntary nationwide
recall of all real water until the
safety of our product is clearly
established
if i thought we were making people sick
i wouldn't have made it but
this videotaped deposition of a former
real water employee
obtained by cbs news raises serious
questions about how they made the water
last fall
casey aiken who was hired after working
for strip clubs
said he had no experience in chemistry
and only a couple hours of what he
called
hands-on training but he was the one in
charge of mixing a liquid concentrate
into the water
here at the company's offices outside
las vegas
as we said here today you don't have any
idea what was in the liquid
concentration exactly
and you don't know where it came from
not clue eakin said in september or
october he was mixing a new batch in the
tanks
and got a low reading on a meter he was
using to measure the water's alkalinity
level
so he called his manager brent jones son
blaine
seen here in another company video to
ask what to do
he told you to add more concentrate
correct but he didn't tell you how much
no he didn't tell me how much aiken said
he decided to add
two and a half more gallons of the
concentrate to the water
you do understand that if you
potentially add
more concentrate than you
usually use that there could potentially
be a problem with the water i wouldn't
think so
you would think so no i wouldn't okay
but you don't know what's in the
concentrate
if i'm putting it into somebody that's
ingesting it i would think that it's
safe no matter what
that's my thought the fda is still
investigating but consumer advocates say
the situation
shows the need for stronger regulations
for bottled water
eric olsen with the nrdc it really is
sort of the wild west
out there with a lot of smaller bottlers
facing very infrequent if any
inspections
and testing by the government that's why
the carriers say
they're speaking out we want people to
be aware this can't happen to any more
people
it's happened to enough yeah it's
happened to enough
well the carriers have filed a lawsuit
against real water and a court filing
the company denied the allegations
but the good news here is that
authorities say that all of those young
children were able to be brought back to
health
without liver transplants anthony wow
i'm glad five-year-old hera is okay but
a wild west in the water world it's
pretty scary yeah it is scary i mean pro
tip you don't have to make water
you know it's out there you don't have
to create it
yeah i'm still thinking about little
hera and her family and what they went
through
when he got to me when he said very few
things bring you to
your knees but to see your child at five
possibly
putting your limb car in the back and
limp child in the back of the car
i'm glad people didn't have to have the
liver transplant that's very scary thank
you
all right anna thank you